[Musique]
pendant les premières
secondes, je tremblais littéralement, je veux dire, je
ne pouvais pas
maintenir mon appareil photo stable et euh
après ça, d'une manière ou d'une autre, j'ai réussi à
me ressaisir et à
cliquer sur quelques clichés [
Musique]
la première fois que nous les avons vus, euh pendant l'
observation
C'était très bref, je les ai vus pendant
environ 10 à 15 secondes
et ils sont allés plus profondément dans la jungle le
lendemain, ils ont tué à
environ 100 mètres de l'endroit où nous pouvions
y accéder
et après cela, c'était un jeu d'attente
parce que
nous pouvions les entendre.  en s'accouplant, nous pouvions entendre
leur rose
mais euh, ils ne sortiraient pas avant la
fin de leur mise à mort
et ils avaient une source d'eau très proche,
mais connaissant les habitudes de la panthère
au cours des quatre dernières années, je savais qu'il
sortirait par un chemin particulier, donc
après
le sixième jour, ils sont tous les deux sortis
après une série de cris d'alarme du
singe et du cerf, je veux dire, c'était des
cris d'alarme assourdissants,
alors quand le moment réel s'est produit,
euh Cléopâtre, la femelle est
sortie en premier,
suivie de la panthère et il y avait  une
distance d'environ 10 mètres entre
eux
donc je n'ai pas pu les mettre tous les deux dans
le même cadre
à un moment donné, je savais que Cléopâtre
attendrait la panthère, c'est généralement l'
inverse,
généralement les gros mâles prennent les devants et
euh
suivie par les femelles mais dans ce
couple Cléopâtre était aux commandes
elle était en avance suivie par la panthère à
un moment donné
connaissant le comportement de ces léopards
on sait toujours que
l'un en tête va toujours s'arrêter et
seulement quand l'autre le rejoint
et ils sont  à proximité quand ils
recommenceront à bouger,
donc j'attendais ce moment parce que
j'avais besoin des deux dans un seul cadre
pour raconter cette histoire et je suis content que cela se soit
produit et euh,
heureusement, cela s'est produit environ 50
mètres avant qu'ils n'entrent dans la brousse sur
le  de l'autre côté
donc oui et les deux regarder
ensemble
était un bonus, c'est sûr, ce moment que je peux
revivre pour le reste de ma vie,
chaque jour de ma vie, je peux juste fermer les
yeux et le revivre
[Musique]
j'avais visualisé quelque chose comme ça
depuis que j'ai vu la panthère noire saya,
à quel point ce serait beau de
capturer le léopard et d'
obtenir le contraste du léopard avec
l'ombre noire,
j'étais en fait un animalier depuis le tout
début, je suis né et j'ai grandi dans
les jungles du sud  l'Inde
dans un endroit appelé Dandeli, l'un des
meilleurs habitats de panthères noires
et depuis que je suis enfant, je
me souviens toujours que j'ai toujours voulu être
avec des animaux
comme les oiseaux, en particulier les grands félins,
m'a fasciné dès le début,
mais quelques instants plus tard  la forêt a
en fait changé ma perspective, ce
furent des
moments incroyables où j'ai eu l'impression de
l'avoir vue à travers mes yeux, mais je dois
le montrer au monde
et c'est ainsi que le voyage a commencé. J'ai
acheté mon premier appareil photo en 2009 et je
n'ai jamais regardé en arrière.  après ça
tu